sur bellamy merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors c'est un avis
unanimement partagée par tout le monde
après les paroles aujourd'hui c'est
l'heure des actes qu'on attend bien sûr
ce terrible attentat est en réalité le
résultat de plusieurs années de
plusieurs décennies de démission
collective et il est absolument certain
que nous avons besoin de sortir de notre
torpeur et d'agir enfin efficacement
pour sortir de cette spirale dans
laquelle le terrorisme islamiste
voudraient enfermer la france monsieur b
la mire on parle donc de lutte contre le
terrorisme selon vous comment la riposte
doit s'organiser
comment prioriser cette lutte avant la
première chose à faire c'est identifier
les causes de la situation dans laquelle
nous sommes aujourd'hui la fracturation
de notre pays
elle est causée par la démission de
l'autorité que ce soit à l'école dans
tous les secteurs régaliens les moyens
insuffisants qui ont été allouées
pendant trop longtemps à la police aux
forces de police de gendarmerie à la
justice mais aussi bien sûr fait que
pendant très longtemps nous avons
accueilli une immigration massive qui a
créé cette espèce de fracturation social
par la diversité des modes de vie des
manières de vivre par l'échec de
l'intégration et de l'assimilation
à tout cela il faut répondre aujourd'hui
je crois que maintenant il faut être
très clair nous le voyons très bien
celui qui a frappé ce matin était un
tunisien arrivé tout récemment de
manière illégale
nous avons eu à faire dans les dernières
semaines à des attentes a causé par un
tchétchène par un pakistanais
il est absolument impératif maintenant
de mettre fin à l'immigration massive
qui traverse notre pays de créer un
moratoire sur les entrées légales en
france de suspendre le regroupement
familial et de se donner enfin les
moyens en france comme au plan européen
de lutter efficacement contre
l'immigration illégale de telle sorte
que personne ne puisse entrer en europe
s'il n'y a pas été légalement autorisé
monsieur bellamy au niveau du
renforcement de la sécurité
emmanuel macron l'annoncé 1,3 milliard
sept militaires déployés dans le cadre
de l'opération sentinelle est ce que nos
forces de l'ordre à l'heure actuelle
soit s'est préparé à la menace
terroriste
évidemment il faut renforcer les moyens
de sécurité et bien sûr je le disais
tout à l'heure donner plus de moyens à
la police à la gendarmerie à la justice
pour pouvoir garantir que les lieux en
particulier plus sensibles de notre pays
seront protégés enfin nous le savons
bien le président la république disait
il ya quelques jours à l'occasion de
l'hommage national à samuel pâtit nous
protégerons tous les enseignants autant
qu'il le faudra en réalité nous savons
bien que c'est impossible il est
évidemment impossible de mettre une
personne armée derrière chaque
professeur de notre pays derrière les
850 mille professeurs de tous les degrés
ça ne se produira pas la vraie question
c'est comment faisons-nous en sortez
votre intervenants le disais à l'instant
il est très difficile de détecter la
radicalisation de certains qui vont
passer à l'acte sans jamais s'être
signalé
la vraie question c'est comment
faisons-nous en sorte de reconquérir par
un travail d'intégration d'assimilation
de reconquérir une authentique unité
nationale de garantir que nous n'allons
pas poursuivre dans la voie de cette
fracturation de notre pays que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui pour moi la
première réponse urgente c'est de mettre
fin au flux migratoires massifs que
notre pays accueille depuis très
longtemps
l'année dernière la france a délivré
trois cent mille titres de séjour lego
c'est l'équivalent de la ville de
bordeaux presque de la ville de nantes
qui s'installe en france légalement il
est absolument évident que nous n'avons
pas les moyens de continuer d'accueillir
des flux aussi important alors même que
nous avons devant nous un défi majeur
qui est celui de la communautarisation
de notre pays qui est celui de la montée
de l'islamisme qui est celui de la
montée de ce qu emmanuel macron appelle
pudiquement le séparatisme mais qui
n'est rien d'autre que la confrontation
entre deux manières de vivre deux
visions du monde qui sont radicalement
antagoniques et tout à l'heure votre
invité précédent disait que
l'immigration n'était pas le sujet je
suis désolé je crois qu'on ne peut pas
séparer ce qui est en train de se passer
aujourd'hui de la question migratoire
qui est à mon avis un prix et une forme
de deux prérequis essentiel et
indispensable pour pouvoir réussir à
résoudre ensuite là qui sont
sécuritaires dont nous savons que quoi
qu'il arrive elle et pour longtemps
devant nous
non pourtant monsieur da minha des
attentats qui ont été commis en france
par des français pour le voit dans
d'autres pays des attentats qui sont
commis par des locaux mais pour vous si
je traduis bien vos propos la lutte
contre l'immigration l'a pris au point
la lutte contre le terrorisme la
priorité c'est la lutte contre
l'immigration
c'est de mettre fin effectivement aux
flux migratoires que notre pays
accueille aujourd'hui continue
d'accueillir en provenance de pays qui
sont marquées par une forte culture
musulmane alors même que nous savons
qu'aujourd'hui notre pays est déjà fait
d'une juxtaposition d'îlots
communautaire qui ne se parlent plus
qu'ils ne se connaissent plus et au
terme de cette communautarisation il y a
bien sûr le conflit de ces communautés
est évidemment à la violence que nous
sommes en train de voir sous nos yeux
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous pouvez
donner les noms des personnes qui ont
commis des attentats sur le sol français
au cours des dernières années
oui bien sûr certains étaient nés en
france mais il s'appelait amedi
coulibaly il s'appelait les frères kwasi
c'était évidemment des personnes qui
étaient issus d'une immigration récente
et qui parce qu'ils avaient grandi dans
des quartiers totalement communautariser
avait évidemment été directement le
produit de cette faillite de
l'intégration il ya une faillite de
l'école il ya un échec profond de notre
système éducatif que j'ai dénoncent
comme professeur depuis très longtemps
et au terme de cet échec là évidemment
devant la réalité de cette migration
massive
il y à la violence que nous voyons
surgir aujourd'hui est donc bien sûr je
ne dis pas que la question migratoire
suffira à tout résoudre
il faut investir dans notre sécurité on
dépense aujourd'hui
ddd d'ester dizaines et centaines de
milliards d'euros pour faire face à la
crise sanitaire
il faut que nous puissions nous donner
les moyens à travers les sommes qui sont
débloqués de renforcer notre police
notre gendarmerie de renforcer notre
justice car nous ne disons pas assez
mais nous avons le système judiciaire le
plus sous financés en europe et donc il
ya évidemment un sujet majeur là dessus
mais bien sûr quelle que soit la
compétence quel que soit le courage
quelle que soit l'héroïsme même de nos
forces de police
peu de forces de sécurité il est
totalement évident que nous ne pourrons
pas résoudre le défi sécuritaire qui est
devant nous si nous ne remettions pas
assez de faillite migratoire que
j'évoquais à l'instant